SEAN HANNITY IS NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
MOMENTS AGO PRESIDENT TRUMP
WRAPPING UP ANOTHER MASSIVE
RALLY.
THIS TIME IN BROWARD COUNTY,
FLORIDA.
BY THE WAY, LOOK AT THIS.
SUPPORTERS STOOD IN LINE ALL DAY
TO GET A SPOT INSIDE THIS PACKED
ARENA.
WHICH HAS A CAPACITY OF OVER
20,000 PAIRED WHAT DEMOCRAT CAN
DO THIS?
PRIOR TO THE BIG RALLY,
BILL O'REILLY INTERVIEWED THE
PRESIDENT ON HIS RADIO SHOW.
AND BILL HAS GIVEN US AN
EXCLUSIVE CLIP FROM THE
ONE-ON-ONE INTERVIEW.
GREAT QUESTION A GREAT ANSWER BY
THE PRESIDENT.
WANT TO HEAR THAT.
NEEDLESS TO SAY THE DEMOCRATS
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE HAS ONLY
SOLIDIFIED THE PRESIDENTS BASE
AND IS NOW TURNING INTO AN
UNMITIGATED POLITICAL DISASTER
FOR THE LEFT.
REMEMBER ALL LAST WEEK, THE
MEDIA MOB TELLING THEM THAT
TRUMP IS FINISHED, A BOMBSHELL.
BOMBSHELL, DISASTER, DISASTER.
WELL, THEY WERE AGAIN LYING TO
WE, THE PEOPLE, AS THEY HAVE
BEEN FOR THREE LONG YEARS, FOUR
IF YOU INCLUDE THE ELECTION.
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE POLES,
SUPPORT FOR IN PEACH MINT WITH
INDEPENDENCE.
LOOK AT THIS, IT HAS DROPPED.
LOOK AT THE EMERSON POLE, DOUBLE
DIGIT SWING AMONG INDEPENDENTS.
AS OPPOSITION FOR IMPEACHMENT IS
UP, OH, A WHOPPING 11 POINTS,
MEANING, GOODBYE.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE IT.
MARQUETTE UNIVERSITY POLL
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR
IMPEACHMENT DROPPING BY FOUR
POINTS IN THE SWING STATE.
THE IMPORTANT STATE OF
WISCONSIN.
A POLITICAL POLL SHOWING SUPPORT
FOR IMPEACHMENT HAS DECLINED
NATIONWIDE.
INTEREST IN THE IMPEACHMENT
CHARADE HAS EVEN DIPPED AMONG
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THE 31 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS NOW
REPRESENTING THOSE SWING
DISTRICTS.
THOSE NAMES RIGHT THERE, THAT
THE PRESIDENT CARRIED IN 2016,
THESE GUYS ARE IN FULL PANIC
MODE.
AS REPUBLICAN GROUPS NOW PLAN TO
PLASTER THESE DISTRICTS WITH
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR AD BUYS OVER
THE THANKSGIVING WEEKEND, YOU
KNOW, WHEN FOOTBALL IS RUNNING,
ET CETERA.
A SO-CALLED MODERATE DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE BEGGING THEIR PARTY
LEADERSHIP FOR HELP.
HERE'S THE GREAT IRONY, THOUGH.
IN ALL OF THIS, THE SCHIFF SHOW,
IRONICALLY, IT MAY ACTUALLY HELP
PAY FOR THESE ADS AS AMERICANS
SHOWED THAT THEY HAVE HAD ENOUGH
FROM THIS COMPROMISE CORRUPT
CONGENITAL LIAR.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN DONATING
RECORD AMOUNTS OF MONEY TO HELP
THE PRESIDENT AND HELP
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES.
HE IS PAYING FOR THIS.
THANK YOU.
I GUESS WE HAVE TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE CONGENITAL LIAR NOMADIC
LIAR.
ONE LAWMAKER TELLING POLITICO
"IT'S LIKE SOMEBODY TAPED OUR
ARMS TO OUR SIDE AND PUNCHED US
IN THE FACE."
OVER THE WEEKEND, DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKER FROM MICHIGAN, ONCE
SUPPORTED IMPEACHMENT, NOW SAYS
SHE DOESN'T.
WELL, THE VALUE OF KICKING TRUMP
OUT OF OFFICE.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS THE SAME
DISTRICT.
LISTEN.
>> YOU CAN CENSOR.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT.
SO THERE ARE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
ACTIVITIES THAT YOU CAN TAKE
UNDER THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
WE ARE SO CLOSE TO AN ELECTION.
I WILL TELL YOU SITTING HERE
KNOWING HOW DIVIDED THIS COUNTRY
IS, I DON'T SEE THE VALUE OF
TAKING THEM OUT OF OFFICE.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN WARRENS
HAS NOW RECANTED THOSE REMARKS
AND IS NOW FALLING IN LINE.
WE CAN TELL YOU WHY, PROBABLY
IMMENSE PRESSURE FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP, THE
SQUAD, AND YES, THE COMPROMISE
CORRUPT CONGENITAL LIAR.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS IS NOT
LOOKING GOOD FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE HELPING THE PRESIDENT
WIN.
EVEN THE MOD STOMACH MOB IN THE
MEDIA IS TAKING NOTE.
LOOK AT JONATHAN SWAN, AXIOS
SAID THIS HAS NOT BEEN
ENCOURAGING FROM A DEMOCRATIC
POINT OF VIEW.
LOOK AT THIS, OVER THERE ON THE
CONSPIRACY TV CHANNEL, AREA 51
RACHEL MADDOW, YES, ROZ WELL
RACHEL, AND CHUCKIE TODD, WHO
WILL NEVER BE ANYWHERE NEAR AS
GREAT AS TIM RUSS WICK,
CONCEDING THAT THE SCHIFF SHOW
DID NOT CLEAR THE POLITICAL BAR,
AND MADE SOME DUMB ANALYSIS
ABOUT THE LEGAL BAR, BUT HE DOES
NOT KNOW WHAT HE IS TALKING
ABOUT.
WAS HE LISTENING TO HIS LUNATIC
COLLEAGUES ON THE CONSPIRACY
CHANNEL MSNBC.
ONE REPORTER SAYS, THE POLE
SHOULD BE A VERY CLEAR WARNING
TO THE DEMOCRATS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DO THINK AT THIS POINT, IT
IS SORT OF A WARNING SIGN FOR
THEM.
IF THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO DO A
PUBLIC SENTIMENT AT ALL WITH
THOSE FIVE HEARINGS, WITH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, AND COMING
FORWARD AND TESTIFYING AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT, THAT IS A PROBLEM
FOR THEM.
IT SHOULD BE A HIGH POINT FOR
THEM IN TERMS OF MAKING A CASE
FOR THE VOTERS.
>> Sean: TONIGHT IT IS NOT
JUST THE POLLS ON IMPEACHMENT
THAT SHOULD CONCERN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HEADLINE
READS "A VOTED DEMOCRATIC, NOW
THEY SUPPORT TRUMP, WHAT THEY
ARE REFERRING TO IS NEW DATA
SHOWING THAT DEMOCRATS DID OKAY
IN THE 2018 ELECTIONS,
DONALD TRUMP DID NOT DO ANYWHERE
NEAR AS BAD IN THE FIRST WELL,
MIDTERM ELECTION AS SAY, OBAMA
AND CLINTON.
BUT THE TWO THIRDS OF THE
BATTLEGROUND STATE VOTERS THAT
CHOSE TRUMP IN 2016, BUT
SELECTED DEMOCRATS AND THE
MIDTERMS, THEY ARE GOING BACK TO
TRUMP IN 2020.
W.H.I.P. SEE DAISY.
IF "THE NEW YORK TIMES" SAYS
TWO-THIRDS IS PROBABLY 98%.
MEANWHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO
SEEING A GROUNDSWELL OF SUPPORT
AMONGST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
SUPPORTERS.
SIX SEPARATE POLES ARE HUGE.
NEW POLLS, 16-34% OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND VOTERS
APPROVE WITH THE PRESIDENT.
KEEP IN MIND, HE ONLY GARNERED
8% OF THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTE
IN 2016.
WE WILL GIVE YOU ALL OF THE
ANALYSIS OF WHY THIS IS
HAPPENING IN JUST A MOMENT.
AND ALSO BE JOINED BY
BEN CARSON.
SPECIFICALLY WE WILL ASK, HOW
HAS THE PRESIDENT HELPED
MINORITY COMMUNITIES MORE IN
THREE YEARS THEN THE DESTRUCTIVE
POLICIES, AND BY THE WAY,
INORDINATELY, THE IMPACT ON THE
MINORITY COMMUNITIES OF BIDEN
AND OBAMA.
IT IS NOW PERFECTLY CLEAR,
UKRAINIAN IMPEACHMENT, THE COUP
ATTEMPT IS NOW A POLITICAL
DUMPSTER FIRE.
WE, YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
YOU ARE NOT BUYING THE B.S. THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN SELLING NOW
FOR THREE LONG YEARS, WE HAVE
HAD ENOUGH.
IN THE WHEELS ARE ALREADY IN
MOTION.
SO JUST AS WE PREDICTED, THE
SCHIFF SHOW IS NOW HEADED TO THE
JERRY NADLER SCHIFF SHOW AND THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, SO THAT HE
CAN TURN THIS FLAMING PILE OF
GARBAGE AND CRAP INTO AN
OFFICIAL IMPEACHMENT HEARING.
GOOD LUCK ON THE HEARSAY HE
SAID, SHE SAID, AND TURN IT INTO
EVIDENCE.
THE ONE WITNESS KEPT THAT CAN
ACTUALLY TESTIFY WITHOUT
OFFERING OPINION OR HEARSAY,
THAT ONE GUY, SONDLAND ON WHAT
THAT PRESIDENT ACTUALLY SAID.
HE IS ON RECORD SAYING I HEARD
THE PRESIDENT SAY, WHAT DO YOU
WANT FOR UKRAINE?
I WANT NOTHING.
NO QUID PRO QUO.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO WORK OUT
WELL IN THE SENATE WHEN THE
RULES OF EVIDENCE, THE FEDERAL
RULES OF EVIDENCE ARE APPLIED.
OF COURSE NADLER WILL TRY HIS
BEST IN THE WITCH TRIAL, THE
COUP ATTEMPT WILL CONTINUE
PAIRED REMEMBER 1998, THIS IS
THE SAME JERRY NADLER.
THAT GUY RIGHT THERE, RAILING
AGAINST IMPEACHMENT SAYING, IT
WAS IN UNDOING OF A NATIONAL
ELECTION.
AND VOTES WERE BEING RIPPED AWAY
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NADLER DID NOT EVEN WANT THE
STARR REPORT, WHICH THE
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL STATUTE
REQUIRED TO BE RELEASED TO BE
RELEASED.
MAYBE BECAUSE IT LISTED 11
SPECIFIC GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT
INCLUDING REAL FELONIES AGAINST
HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS
BILL CLINTON.
REMEMBER THIS.
>> MR. STARR IS TRANSMITTING,
TRANSMITTING A LETTER TO THE
SPEAKER IN THE MINORITY LEADER,
MADE IT CLEAR THAT MUCH OF THIS
MATERIAL IS FEDERAL MATERIAL,
MATERIAL BY LAW, UNLESS
CONTRAVENED BY VOTE OF THE HOUSE
MUST BE KEPT SECRET.
IT'S GRAND JURY MATERIAL.
IT REPRESENTS STATEMENTS WHICH
MAY OR MAY NOT BE TRUE BY
VARIOUS WITNESSES, SALACIOUS
MATERIAL.
ALL KINDS OF MATERIAL THAT WOULD
BE UNFAIR TO RELEASE.
>> Sean: NOW NADLER IS IN A
SPEARHEAD, IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDING AGAINST DONALD TRUMP,
WHETHER THEY ARE NO SPECIFIC
GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT
WHATSOEVER.
HE PAID A HELL OF A LOT OF MONEY
TO PAULA JONES AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THE LEVEL OF HYPOCRISY IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA KNOWS NO BOUNDS.
OF COURSE KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS
ALL MUCH TO DO ABOUT NOTHING,
BECAUSE THE SENATE WILL NEVER
VOTE TO CONVICT.
AND INSTEAD WILL FOLLOW THE
FEDERAL RULES OF EVIDENCE, WHICH
MEANS NO HEARSAY WILL BE
ADMITTED.
NO OPINION WITNESSES WILL BE
HEARD, THAT MEANS NOBODY WE
HEARD FROM IN THE SCHIFF SHOW.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL FINALLY BE
ABLE TO MOUNT A DEFENSE.
THAT IS HUGE.
AND EARLIER TODAY HE EASILY JUST
RIPPED APART THE DEMOCRATS
FAULTY NARRATIVE DURING AN
INTERVIEW WITH BILL O'REILLY.
THIS IS ON HIS RADIO SHOW.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> YOU HAD TO DO THE PHONE CALL
WITH THE UKRAINE PRESIDENT
AGAIN, WOULD YOU MENTION
JOE BIDEN?
>> WELL, IS VERY UNIMPORTANT
LIEN, AND AS YOU KNOW,
JOE BIDEN'S SON BECAME RICH AS
SOONEST JOE BIDEN BECAME
VICE PRESIDENT.
AND IN MY WAY OF THINKING, THAT
IS TOTALLY CORRUPT.
WE HAVE TO LOOK FOR CORRUPTION.
WE ARE SENDING THEM TREMENDOUS
AMOUNTS OF MONEY.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE SENDING IT
FOR CORRUPT PURPOSES.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT BOTHERS
ME IS WHY ISN'T FRANCE AND
GERMANY AND, YOU KNOW, NATO, YOU
COULD SAY.
WHY AREN'T THESE OTHER COUNTRIES
AND INSTITUTIONS, WHY ARE THEY
PAYING SOME OF -- WHY IS IT
ALWAYS THE SUCKER UNITED STATES?
>> Sean: BAM, THE PRESIDENT IS
ON OFFENSE.
AT THIS POINT THE DEMOCRATS
DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THEY HAVE THE
VOTES FOR IMPEACHMENT.
TO THOSE 31, WELL, DEMOCRATS IN
TRUMP WON DISTRICTS IN 2016,
THEY FACE PERIL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS WITHSTOOD
THREE PLUS YEARS, THE COUNTRY
HAS WITHSTOOD THREE PLUS YEARS
OF WHAT IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
POLITICAL ONSLAUGHT.
NO PRIOR ADMINISTRATION, NO
PRIOR PRESIDENT HAS EVER FACED
THIS LEVEL OF HATRED, RAGE,
PSYCHOSIS, AND VITRIOL.